ali abdul he is a creator he is a
entrepreneur who came first at cambridge
and he is a productivity expert the way
that i define productivity is just kind
of using my time well and working on
things that are meaningful to me and
optimizing for happiness i feel
unproductive when i know there is
something i want to do and i am not
doing the thing
because i'm scrolling instagram
procrastination is a problem with
getting started and so the key to
overcoming procrastination is that
little nudge at the start towards
actually getting started there are a few
a few hacks the one that i use all the
time is the the two minute rule two
minutes is all you need to change your
life
the way i try and remind myself of this
point of i i am enough is thinking and
and really trying to internalize that
the journey is more important than the
destination we do need a destination but
really like am i enjoying myself day to
day and am i kind of
living
the dream as it were day to day and not
and not so much worrying about the goal
at the end of it
[Music]
productivity procrastination
two things that all people aspiring to
success or really aspiring to get
anything done
often struggle with
today we're going to try and solve that
problem today i'm joined by ali abdul he
is a creator on youtube he's got
millions and millions of subscribers he
is a entrepreneur he's a cambridge
graduate who came first at cambridge and
he is a productivity expert and honestly
he's read more books than anyone i think
i've ever met on the subject but
generally about how to become the best
version of yourself
this conversation isn't just about
productivity and procrastination it ends
up twisting and turning through a bunch
of different topics like relationships
and friendships and the meaning of life
and happiness
but what else would you expect from this
podcast you're going to enjoy this
conversation ali is an incredibly
intelligent intellectual compassionate
self-aware individual and he's able to
talk in a way that simplifies complex
ideas for people like me and you
so without further ado
my name is stephen bartlett and this is
the dire river ceo
i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
i really start here with all my guests
because i think it's so foundation
foundational to everything that they
then say they're after is getting a bit
of context as to
who you are where you came from and the
environment in which ali was created
oh interesting question
okay so
um
i was born in karachi in pakistan in
1994 so i'm 27 now
and when i was two years old my mom and
dad divorced and my mom moved us to
lesotho in southern africa uh it's a
country most people haven't heard of
it's surrounded by south africa like
landlocked by south africa and we were
there for about five six years growing
up
uh at that point
you know my mom really valued education
she was working as a doctor and she knew
the educational opportunities in
southern africa in the suture were not
great and so we made a plan to move to
the uk until we came to the uk in 2003
she started working here as a doctor and
we moved around a little bit in
different areas in the uk and it was
really in in secondary school uh that i
did in south indonesia essex where
i discovered kind of entrepreneurship
under the internet and computers and
stuff
and basically all throughout school
i'd be the kid getting like decent
grades and everything like that but the
thing i like i would
i would look forward to going home so
that i could do some more coding or
tinker on some websites or try and show
my services as a freelance graphic
designer or something for five dollars
here and there and i was making kind of
you know a little bit of money i i lied
about my age on paypal i pretended i was
18 when i was actually like 13 and
i was getting like 5 10 from these small
businesses uh here and there and
thinking oh my god i'm making money on
the internet this is incredible and then
as i went through school uh me and my
friends we were all quite interested in
the entrepreneurship stuff we were all
we were doing like well in school and i
was like oh it would be cool to go to
oxford or cambridge would be cool to do
medicine
but really my passion at the time was
going home and and tinkering with
websites
and so that was kind of the environment
that i grew up in then when i went to
university you know thankfully i got a
place for medicine at cambridge which
was great awesome experience just on
that point there so you you were
tinkering on websites and loving it
that's the thing you were like running
home from school to do yeah um but then
you go for medicine what was the driving
force behind you deciding not to do the
tinkering on websites for a living and
going and doing medicine i mean i you
said that your mother was a doctor yeah
so i think when you grow up in the sort
of environment that i did whereby
parents and doctors
all of my mom's friends were doctors
everyone we knew had like doctor parents
there are so few viable careers where
you think you know what am i what are my
job options in life well it's either
doctor or lawyer or engineer like it's
literally just those three you don't
even realize that other jobs even exist
not in like a
a way where the parents are telling you
this consciously but more like just the
narrative that you absorb from the
people you're around is that i could be
a doctor or engineer or a lawyer
and so that was always in the back of my
mind that oh it would be cool to be a
doctor one day
and when i was around 16 i can i ask why
yeah
i think because
doctor seemed like a prestigious thing
and i think i i remember even when i was
like six and seven when people used to
ask me what i would want to be when i
was older i used to say either a
neurosurgeon or a gastroenterologist not
even knowing what that meant but it was
just like a big word that would make me
feel cool that oh yeah and then the
adults that i would speak to would be
like oh hello
fancy
so that in and of itself yeah where does
prestige exist one would assume that it
exists in the mind of others
like do you know what i mean like so
that's what i if you had said to me i
really want to save people's lives i
really had a real high desire to like
save lives and then i'd be like okay
that's the voice inside but when when
it's like status then it was very much
status and prestige and that's the thing
that i think about to this day
a lot about like now that i've taken a
break from medicine
you know often if i'm if i'm having
conversations with my mum
the she'll try and talk me back into
doing medicine again really and one of
her kind of bargaining chips on that
front is oh but think about the prestige
you know medicine has a certain prestige
around it that being a youtuber doesn't
and that's always like oh you know it's
that that side of me that's like well i
want to carve my own path i don't i
don't care about status and status and
prestige and then there's the other half
where it's still like a kind of a
narrative going through my life that i
need to optimize for like this sort of
old world prestige instead of happiness
instead of happiness yeah which is
bizarre isn't it it's completely bizarre
yeah this is a
strange like it's a cultural thing as
well largely i think with i think with
you know my mom dropped out of school
when she was seven years old
so
doctor lawyer
anything with prestige was the correct
answer yeah um
maybe that's because
this is me just guessing out loud when
you come from when you're an immigrant
family
one of the actual biggest predictors of
happiness was financial security and
being a doctor i was like maybe yeah i
think i think that's a big part of it
where with my with uh with our parents
generation especially especially as
immigrants
seeing
other people who are happy correlated
with other people who had like a big
house and like nice cars and we're going
on holidays
equals financial success equals oh those
people did well in their traditional
career of banking or medicine or
engineer or law
and the narrative of like someone like
you entrepreneur social media big
company that it just didn't
it just wasn't really a thing in our
parents generation and you said they're
like going on holidays
but i think if in go back to my like the
village in nigeria where my mom's from
having a good job was actually like
survival it was like being able to eat
it was like
much more just
much lower things on maslow's hierarchy
of needs it was just like being able to
survive and that not having a job in an
education was like pain from food
no health care no education
whereas as you say like in the western
world when you grow up here yeah it
means
lamborghini and holiday and stuff but
so you take that you take that decision
anyway driven by your
by an external narrative to go and
become a doctor uh external i think
there was also partly an internal
narrative and i'm not sure how much of
this is me just bullshitting myself but
when i was 16 i decided i made a
conscious decision do i want to do
computer science and do the tinkering
with websites thing or do i want to do
medicine
i think
what i reasoned at the time was was two
things number one medicine is six years
at university computer science is only
three everyone says university is great
ergo six years is better than three
years therefore medicine makes sense
but the other thing that i thought was
that it would be more interesting for my
life to be a doctor who knows how to
code than to be
a coder who knows how to code
and it was like really that decision
where i realized okay why don't i do
medicine keep the coding website east
kind of stuff on the side so that i can
eventually do some kind of tech startup
thing related to medicine and then
medicine becomes a side hustle in a way
before i had the terminology of the frey
side hustle
and so it ended up not quite working out
that way but but certainly from my first
year of med school onwards i knew that i
was not going to be a doctor full time i
was going to do medicine for fun and i
was going to make money on the side
through a tech startup or something like
that and did you try tech startup uh a
little bit so in my first year of uni uh
second year of uni i started a company
that helped other kids get into med
school and then so that was like
in-person courses but then eventually
because me and my brother knew how to
code we turned this into a software
online question bank for the different
med school admissions programs
and so that would that was it sort of
like you know subscription billing
software as a service kind of product
uh which was the closest i got to a tech
startup i i dabbled with a few like
medical tech things i used to do
freelance app design and web design for
med tech startups while i was when i was
at uni but when the youtube channel
started and that really started taking
off i sort of realized that
the thing i actually want to do is is
teaching rather than coding
um and then
something something that you talk about
in the book is kind of reflecting on
your life and figuring out what are your
values what is the thing that you
have that intrinsic motivation for
and for me i always had that intrinsic
motivation for business type stuff and
also for teaching uh i used to do
tutoring when i was like from the age of
13 up until now
and those were the times where i felt
most alive in a way where i was teaching
someone else
um and the nice thing about being a
youtuber is that it's just teaching at
scale and so i think i found that thing
that drives me intrinsically
um that so now tech startup is sort of a
oh backup option
if youtube channel fails if i get struck
off the medical register
i can probably start a text startup or
or words to that effect i always find it
a little bit weird that someone would
just like go on youtube and make a video
you know what i mean like that when you
hear about the first time where these
big youtubers started whether it's like
true geordi who i've spoken to here or
alfie days who i think became like the
biggest one of the biggest youtubers in
the country like that first decision
to record yourself usually in your
bedroom on a [ __ ] camera talking to
nobody yep is a little bit weird do you
know what i mean
how did it start for you
it started for me so
i i harbor dreams of being a youtuber
since about 2009. why um because i used
to follow uh people like coach schneider
and sam tsui who were kind of youtube
cover artists they would produce covers
of popular songs
and those covers were amazing like they
filmed them beautifully arranged them
beautifully and i had a few friends who
are really good at singing and i fancy
myself you know i was quite into maths i
like the idea of playing multiple
musical instruments so i thought i want
to be the sort of youtuber where i can
play along to songs and my friends who
are actually good at singing can sing
along to those songs and that's the sort
of youtuber i want to be
and so i sort of had a few like
sort of stop starting moments over the
over those like next 10 years
kind of trying and failing at this
but ultimately the reason i became a
youtuber was because it was content
marketing for my medical school
admissions business
where i was helping people get into med
school teaching them how to do well in
these exams and no one was really
creating decent content for free on the
internet about those exams there was
these kind of corporations creating
boring corporate looking stuff
um and i saw that gap in the market i
was like great if i can create these
sort of tutorials on youtube content
marketing people will watch my tutorials
free and if they like me enough they'll
sign up to the course
and that's why i started speaking to a
camera in my bedroom it was like all
right guys here are some tips for
section one of the b-man you know
section one is all about critical
thinking the 60 minutes and 35 questions
and bloody blind here's how you do it
and i was so familiar with that stuff
having taught it for five years um
that
that started to do reasonably okay early
on in the days where i had like 51
subscribers 52 you know refreshing the
youtube app every day to be like oh my
god i've got another view
um
and it sort of morphed from there was
there a tipping point where you thought
[ __ ] this is gonna be
bigger than the
the thing that i intended this to
support
yeah that tipping point was my first
video that went viral
uh and it was a video about how to study
for exams um
this was one of those weird
weird things that i look back on where
when i started youtube it was in june of
2017.
i knew that i wanted to make this video
this sort of how to study for exams
evidence-based tips at some point
further down the line it was a topic
that i'd researched extensively i like
people would come to me asking for help
on how to study for their exams there's
actually a whole body of like
psychological research on this that we
just don't get taught in school around
what are the actually most effective
ways to learn
and so i knew i wanted to make a video
about this but i knew that i wanted that
to be like my 100th video rather than my
first video because i knew that i knew
nothing about cameras or editing or
anything and i reasoned it would take me
a hundred videos of being bad at it
before i could make a video that was
actually good
and i thought to myself to myself okay i
really want to put all my everything
into this 100th video so that this video
can potentially go big and that's kind
of what ended up happening i think it
was my 81st video or something rather
than my 100th but that video went viral
i i had like 4 000 subscribers before
just sort of slowly building up and then
over the next few weeks it just exploded
up to like 20 000 25 000
um and i was getting all these comments
from people who knew me in real life
being like oh i've seen your video i
didn't realize you're a youtuber
and that was the tipping point um
which really sort of started that
exponential growth trajectory that kind
of you talk about in the compounding
chapter yeah yeah yeah about that again
so there's two things there the first
this i'll just do them in the order in
which i i thought of them um
okay because you mentioned compounding
there what have you learned from your
experience on youtube about the
importance of of consistency
um
and also from what you kind of what
typically happens with viral videos is
just there's
it's so impossibly hard to predict the
outcome right so a lot of people say a
lot of people on youtube will make
videos called how to make a viral video
and in marketing it's all like here are
the secret sauce here are the secret
principles but in reality
you can only you can ha you can guess
a couple of principles but
the outcome is hard to predict so what
have you learnt about consistency but
then also being able to predict the
outcome
yeah uh
when i was listening to your your
compounding chapter i just found myself
like nodding along like an absolute
maniac to everything you were saying i
think it applies so much to youtube uh
these days i i teach people how to be
part-time youtubers and the thing i say
is that
if you make one video every week for two
years then i 100 guarantee it will
change your life i can't put any numbers
on it i can't tell you you'll have 100
000 subscribers or how much money you'll
be making but i can 100 guarantee it
will change your life at the very least
in terms of the skills and the
experience and the contacts and the
friends you're going to make through
that process but you have to put out one
video a week and you have to do it for
at least two years
um
i just asked on that then on that point
there
what is it that will would make someone
do that
because i mean that's like
[ __ ] clean the floor every day for
two years and i promise you'll work out
for you
like
people don't seem to be able to do those
kinds of things without some kind of
intrinsic driver so i'm like i'm curious
because you could say that to a million
people you could broadcast that through
a tunnel and 95
plus will still fail
so what is it that makes people from
your your experience but also yeah from
your own life makes them do the work
without guarantee of outcome
yeah i think
again i i feel like there's a bit of a
cop-out because this is stuff that you
talk about uh like in enjoying the
process and this is kind of the theme of
the book that i'm writing around how
you know it's actually quite hard to
show up week after week not see any
results and not see the views and the
subscribers going up and stuff
particularly quickly
but the thing that makes it bearable the
thing that makes it fun is actually
enjoying the process and shifting away
from outcome oriented goals like a
certain number of views a certain number
of subscribers and more towards
goals that are 100 within our control
like i just want to make two videos a
week and if i'm happy with the video
then it goes out and in fact even if i'm
not happy with the video it goes out
anyway and everyone i know who has
succeeded on youtube has had that kind
of attitude at some point i just have to
get that video out every tuesday without
fail it's not an option it's going to
get done
and
you know like you say in when we talk
when we talk about compounding
that that video on day 1 isn't going to
do anything the video on day 2 or day 3
or day 24 is not going to do anything
but you find when you're on day 300 and
day 600 oh
actually all of this stuff has been
compounding very very slowly and then
the results happen really really really
slowly and then all at once as soon as
you just get that one video that that
goes viral that is i think that's the
chapter where i talk about the eighth
wonder of the world yeah that's it with
warren buffett and my dog pablo being
the opposing investor and i genuinely i
think i learned that lesson
when i wrote the book when i look back
on my life and i thought about all the
things that compounded in my favor
whether it was like my honestly it's
going to be keeping facts with you
my teeth had some problems with my teeth
and i thought do you know why and i
probably referenced this in the book
like i i hadn't been brushing one of my
teeth properly and it never mattered
today or tomorrow the day after but
there i was in that dentist's chair but
having my teeth [ __ ] pulled out and
then my instagram was the same
um health and fitness at the moment the
same my business was the same and it
just goes to show that it's not those
key critical big decisions we make to
drop out it's that like yeah it's that
the compounding small almost uh
irrelevant decisions yeah but people
don't they because i heard you started
working out i did yeah and then you
stopped uh oh so i've had a personal
trainer now for the last kind of eight
months there you go amazing and uh you
know i've been i've been going on and
off with the workout thing since the age
of 18 and never done it properly until i
got a personal trainer where now i'm
having to show up i'm paying someone 30
quid an hour to basically just be with
me while i'm doing stuff
and that has been the thing that's given
me the most results
uh
so
i think
whatever like i i find in my life
for things for things that i actually
care about where i'm like okay i
actually care about becoming a happy
sexy millionaire or whatever
let me try and figure out ways that will
remove my own
need for discipline and willpower from
that equation
and instead get an accountability buddy
or get a coach or
pay a friend 100 quid if i don't do the
thing this was what my brother and i did
when we were trying to motivate
ourselves i was doing songwriting he was
doing stand-up comedy like right if we
don't do this every thursday for half an
hour we're going to pay each other 50
quid
things like that to remove the choice
the motivation the willpower the
discipline that all
the more of that can be outsourced to
someone else or removed completely the
more i find i actually get stuff done
and then i don't have to worry about it
cause i'm like okay this is taken care
of i just show up i guess you're
removing you're moving the mood as
opposed to like removing it you're
moving it to another pact like near il
refers to it as what you've described as
a financial pact where now your
motivation is to not lose 50 quid it's
like because that is that's a greater
motivating force than you have within
yourself to work out that's interesting
is that sustainable
no it's not it's not okay um
this is all the stuff that i'm
researching for the for for the book at
the moment um and you talk about this as
well like in intrinsic and extrinsic
motivation
and the way that i think of it when i
think back on my life is that
everything that i've done sustainably
has been because of intrinsic motivation
i've genuinely enjoyed the thing
but
you can genuinely enjoy a thing
and still find it really hard to get
started i think that's where the biggest
procrastination comes in for all of us
where it's actually just showing up to
the gym that's the hard part like once
you're there it's kind of easy it's
writing those first 10 words because
once you've started writing the first 10
it's kind of easier to enjoy the process
of writing the rest of them
and so and so the way i think about it
is to get over that like hump of
procrastination that activation energy
to get started at that point i will use
every tool that in my arsenal to just
just get me to do the thing for two
minutes because i think once once you do
the thing for two minutes it becomes so
much easier to actually enjoy the
process and and and sustain it and and
you're so right when it comes to
procrastination like that getting
started point um i've again just learned
this from podcast guests that i've had
near aiella and i refer to him he he
said to me one day on this podcast he
was like people procrastinate usually
because there's
um a great deal of psychological
discomfort surrounding starting the task
and a lot of the time especially with a
gym or even an essay that psychological
discomfort is like you don't have the
answers so i don't know how to use the
machines at the gym or i don't actually
have i don't feel competent enough to
even write this essay so i'm just going
to do the [ __ ] dishes yeah it's like
i'm going to hoover the whole house and
anyone else's house that needs hoovering
today exactly um you you made a video
about procrastination didn't you yeah
yeah break that down for me what's it
what's in the video
um so the video is called how to stop
procrastinating right yeah um
so
the the way thing about procrastination
basically
procrastination is a problem with
getting started um kind of this this law
of inertia uh newton's first law that if
something is at rest it will continue to
stay at rest but if something's moving
it will continue to move without needing
an external force and so the key to
overcoming procrastination is that
little
that little nudge at the start towards
actually getting started
and all of the techniques around that
like in the whole like psychology
research or research around this is just
around making make make it as easy as
possible um so reduce all of the
friction to doing it if you want to
learn the guitar then have the guitar by
your sofa rather than in the wardrobe
where you're never going to see it and
if it's out of sight it's out of mind
you're never going to do it
there's like the external environmental
friction towards doing the thing but
then there's also the internal friction
it's like those narratives that we tell
ourselves the
uh the psychological discomfort of going
to the gym that i don't want to see how
other people are going to see me
though
even even having having the wrong sort
of goal like if my goal in writing the
book is i already want to hit the new
york times bestseller list
then it's really really hard to bring
myself to write anything because now
every single word i have to write has to
be in new york times best-selling word
whereas if the goal is to be honest i
just want to write a book i'm proud of
that's fun to fun to write that's
actually within my control and it
becomes so much easier to get started at
doing the thing
um so to overcome procrastination we
need to eliminate external friction i.e
the environmental stuff we need to try
our best to get rid of the internal
friction like the emotional side of it
the mindset the perfectionism the the
fear the discomfort
and then if we still need help there are
a few a few hacks the one that i use all
the time is the the two-minute rule
which is where i will genuinely convince
myself i'm only gonna do it for two
minutes uh and if i want i'm allowed to
stop after the two minutes because two
minutes is better than nothing but like
95 percent of the time i decide to
continue because
two minutes is all you need to change
your life yeah i should tweet that
that's good so yeah that's really good
and i that two-minute thing is
fascinating to me because i one of the
things that um i see as another
psychological barrier to starting is
people view it as like they view the
challenge as mount everest whereas
like they've got them
i'll say it another way they view the
challenge as moving mount everest and
really if they viewed it as just like
moving one pebble at a time it becomes
such a simple task yeah and i get this a
lot when entrepreneurs ask me they say
steve i want to start a business where
do i start and you can hear in the
question that they see it as moving
mount everest and i'm like well today
all you have to do is think of a name
just think of like 50 names make a short
list of names and then we'll revisit it
tomorrow and then tomorrow maybe think
of you know go and check if the
website's available and then we'll
revisit the day after yeah and when it
becomes that and when it becomes sort of
really small itemized one small step at
a time and you're not having to get from
stairs zero to a thousand
immediately it becomes so you know the
psychological discomfort fades away
it feels achievable and that your two
minute rule is doing a similar thing
where it's saying well today i've only
got to do just just if i can open the
word document and write a title and then
we're done you know and
so that's fascinating what about
you we're going to see something else
there yeah i mean i just just to your
point there um have you have you come
across the blog wait but why no oh it's
incredible you should definitely
interview tim urban when you're in
america oh i don't know i literally
yesterday went on his instagram and sent
media oh great yeah he's awesome any
podcast he's ever been on i've been like
this is so sick uh he has a great blog
post series about overcoming
procrastination and the way he refers to
that that point you just made is that um
there are lots of tasks that are very
like vague and icky
and you have to be able to uniquify a
task uh and something like start a
business is icky something like learn to
code is icky because like what the hell
does that even mean like where do you
even start whereas brainstorm 10 ideas
for a name and pick one of them is a
very clearly defined next action step
and so i get this with students all the
time where people are like oh i don't
have the motivation to study for my
chemistry exam it's like what's on your
to-do list study for my chemistry exam
that's never gonna happen read chapter
one and answer questions four to five
are a reasonable thing a reasonably
defined next action step
and so what i do is anytime i find
myself procrastinating from something i
think okay am i procrastinating because
i actually
the task is too icky i i don't know what
i have to do because once i know what i
have to do i can then do it for two
minutes and it gets done
speaking about productivity um as you
guys know i'm i'm the biggest fuel
consumer in the world and i have been
for many many many years and i always
get asked what my favorite heel products
are and i have them here in front of me
the first product that i fell in love
with with huel because it's
nutritionally complete it tastes amazing
i have no time in my life but i also
want don't want my diet to be
compromised when my life gets really
really busy as it always has um ended up
being um is this berry flavor ready to
drink cure that was where that was where
my journey with heel began the next
product that i fell in love with at huel
was the banana flavor ready to drink for
me it just tastes better than the berry
and i already think the berry tastes
amazing funnily from speaking to huel a
lot of people's favorite flavor is the
chocolate flavor
i've never taken a huge liking to the
chocolate flavor but to be honest i
don't really eat much chocolate in any
facet of my life
or drink it at all and now the product
which i have every single day without
fail and probably because i'm in that
phase where i'm working out every day
without exception
and i want to make sure that my gains
from working out whether it's becoming
more lean or becoming more strong are
captured is the protein um here which
has just come out and as you can see if
anyone thinks i'm bullshitting about how
much i like heal this tub is basically
empty so huel if you're listening please
can i have a top-up i will buy it don't
worry um but honestly and i say this
with full honesty 100 honesty um i
genuinely didn't like protein powders
before maybe i'm lazy not the type of
guy that likes to mix things and this is
my favorite flavor protein ever the
salted caramel heel which i talk about
all the time they also have a ton of
other flavors they're all actually on
top of my fridge there but i'm starting
with this one i've basically finished it
and then i'll work my way through the
others and give you a little bit of a
review on those i it's such as i always
say in this podcast it's such an honor
to be able to talk about a product that
you use many times a day i had the heel
ready to drink this morning i'll have
this after my workout which is after
this podcast and in terms of
productivity optim um and operating at
your best then that is what huell is all
about
you know people talk about how they'll
put on their to-do list clean house
and it'll sit on a to-do list
and clean up that's a certain big thing
and it'll and that'll sit on your to-do
list for like i don't know two weeks or
whatever but if you do if you time block
and write in your this is what i do on
the weekends because so monday to friday
my schedule is ran by the meetings and
things i have to do so i'm a slave to
the calendar saturday and sunday come
around
i wake up i'm like
okay
i'm like what the [ __ ] how does this
thing work
yeah i'm like it's empty i've got loads
of things i know i could be doing right
now but nothing no one telling me what
to do in a in a life of mine where i'm
told what to do every five minutes
um
so i time block on the weekends which
means clean house would become at 11
till 12 i clean the kitchen
because then it's like time sensitive
and like task specific and that's that's
been an absolute game changer for me
and i also think in the era of working
from home yeah
where
you know people are sat at home they
have uh tasks they have to connect
people always ask the question it's
almost like we prefer this because like
this is literally like the the three
part structure of my book which i've
been like i just having in my head for
the last last few weeks
where like step one is how do we beat
the procrastination how do we get
started with doing the thing and part
two of the book is how do we sustain how
do we actually keep on going doing the
thing
and
uh there's just uh so in in in terms of
mindset the thing that i found that
actually moves the needle is
focusing on trying to make it fun and i
really i really like that word fun like
i think there's something about the word
fun that is so like childish but also
fully speaks to like fun basically means
in intrinsic motivation like something
is sufficiently enjoyable that you do it
for its own sake rather than for the
fact that you've got a sponsored helping
you or you've got a deadline or things
like that
um
there's one
there's one story in particular that i
i i often come back to and that's like
sometime last year i was i was working
at the hospital it was pandemic season
et cetera et cetera and i'd gotten to
the end of like a 13-hour long shift and
i was just about to go home uh and the
nurse said to me oh ali can you put a
candle in this patient her like iv line
is tissued and she needs fluids
overnight and my heart kind of sank i
was like oh no
like if if the nurse wasn't able to put
the cannula in that means there's a
patient with difficult veins it means
it's going to be hard to put this in
and i sort of had this mindset of like
all right then fine
and sort of
grudgingly took out the cannula and got
all the equipment in a tray
and i like as as i was doing this i
there was a patient in the bay next door
where they were just like talking to a
family member or something and saying oh
you know this hospital has been amazing
everyone is so nice and what a pleasure
it is you know freaking love the nhs
kind of vibes
and i realized that in that moment i was
not being like a good
model internally for what i want the nhs
to be and what i want a good doctor to
be and there's something that seth godin
who uh who i've been following for a
while says which is that
it's the difference between have to and
get to
and so i was considering as like oh i
have to put in this cannula and i
remembered that blog post i read from
seth godin where he said instead of
thinking of have to think of it as get
to i realized oh i get to put in this
cannula i get to make a difference in
this patient's lives and life and give
her fluids overnight so that she's not
gonna dehydrate because of her morning
sickness
and just that mindset shift immediately
made me feel so much better about it and
i was like oh i get to do this who cares
if i've been working for 13 hours this
is fun this is privileged this is cool
and i put it in and we had a nice chat
and i felt really great about it
afterwards and now like and so that's
one of the mindset things that i just
always come back to if i'm finding
myself not enjoying something and
therefore my focus goes i get distracted
i procrastinate
instead of thinking i have to do this i
think i get to do this it's like a
gratitude shift yeah
yeah it's like your chapter three or
what was talking about gratitude
and we so quickly fall out of gratitude
when we become so easy to do yeah when
we become like used to the privilege of
our life used to the privilege of our
jobs of our relationships of our kids of
our dog we we think well you know we and
because and the stoic people talk about
this i think i'll probably talk about
this in the book as well because these
are just like
clearly the only idea that i have put
them all in there um how they used to do
that like hedonistic adaptation
um exercises to literally take the
things out of their life that they've
really valued just to remind themselves
of what they had and it kind of seems
like um
gratitude is a very important thing
have you got like a defined gratitude
practice that you do like gratitude
journaling or that kind of stuff
so i the gratitude journaling thing um
takes place in the notes of my phone
where sometimes i feel the need to
remind myself of what i'm really really
grateful for i think i do have a
a bias towards feeling grateful all the
time i really just get overwhelmed
sometimes with like
i'll have like a little flash you'll
probably get this when you think what
the [ __ ] is this yeah like you know
like what the f especially now that i'm
on dragon's den and that was a real
vision of mine when i was like 12 years
old i'm like
oh my this is and i said this in my show
the other day i said um
i said on stage in the drive of a seo
live
i said that um i said to the audience i
said like
i think everybody in this room is living
a life that you once dreamed of living
but you don't you're not even happy
about it because
present you
well if present you has told you that
future you will be even happier when you
get to somewhere else but like this is
it
this was the [ __ ] dream and look at
you living it look at you as your you
know doctors and lawyers and you've got
the job at that brand you always wanted
to work for this is it um
and i i have to do that to myself
sometimes because
yeah um
because if not you'll never get there if
your happiness is always as i said in
the book if it always lives somewhere in
the future behind some goal or at the
attainment of some task or whatever it
always will be there and that was
certainly the case for me and i from
what i read about you
where um
you were talking about like
outcomes and not being to attach the
outcomes sounds like it might have been
similar yeah yeah very much so um i i
have to remind myself on a daily basis
as well um to kind of be
be grateful for for all of the things um
sometimes like if i if if i'm in the
habit of doing like a morning journal
i'll like write down a list of three
things and it's often simple things like
you know this cup of coffee in my hand
or angus or like my housemate and just
like you know this nice chat that we had
and i think like like for me if i don't
remind myself i
i always just think in kind of hustle
mode of like all right cool on to the
next thing on to the next thing on to
the next thing
um but like it was it was pretty cool
yesterday like we we we went on a tour
of gymshark hq up north
and i was just thinking that i can't
believe this is this is my job like i
get to do this for work this is
absolutely sick and even now being here
like this is
sitting here talking to you
is what i get to do for work and if like
i don't know 18 year old me were to
imagine being in this position now i'd
just been like oh my god this is this is
the dream have you come across a guy
called brandon sanderson nope uh he's an
author he
writes he's my favorite author he does
he's incredible like fantasy novels
stormlight archive huge huge uh series
in it there's like a q a phrase that i
always come back to around this point
there's this like um order of knights
they're called the knights radiant and
they have like their like charter their
ideals and their first ideal is life
before death strength before weakness
journey before destination and it's that
final bit of journey before destination
that i remind myself of on a basically
daily basis where
it's it's kind of like miley cyrus thing
of it's the climb it's not about how
fast i get there ain't about what's
waiting on the other side it's the climb
and the way i try and
i try and remind myself of this point of
i i am enough is
thinking and and really trying to
internalize that the journey is more
important than the destination
and i think
we do need a destination like
you know the fact that i want to i don't
know
write this book or whatever like that's
that's a destination but now that i've
got that destination of like cool this
is the direction i want to go at that
point in a dream world i would just
forget about that and now that i'm on
the journey i would enjoy the journey on
its own merit
because you know as you know once you if
you set a goal you hit the god it's like
well happiness started the the joy from
that lasts about five seconds and then
it feels like nothing
even like sometimes it doesn't feel like
anything at all even even for those five
seconds
um and so what i've been realizing a lot
recently is that
yes we're i don't know expanding the
team and moving to an office in london
and like hiring people and bloody blah
blah blah but really like am i enjoying
myself day to day and am i kind of
living
the dream as it were day to day and not
and not so much worrying about the goal
at the end of it one thing that you they
talk about as well um
is
i think it was either 19 chapter chapter
19 and 20. it was around
this thing of
you can yeah ambition versus insecurity
is this thing that you think you want to
do is it coming from within or is it
coming from outside of you
and you talk about values like living in
alignment with your values
do you have any like how how do you
figure out what your values are
it's a really interesting it's a really
interesting um thing um i think
i think one of the the best indicators
of what your values are are
from how you feel that's maybe the most
um fundamental human
stimuli we have which is how something
makes us feel um
slight tangent
and i was talking to someone about this
yesterday
in the world we live in and as the
social media connected from birth
generation we don't understand what our
actual true intrinsic values are very
easily because even if and this is kind
of a controversial topic but who cares
even charity we all think we're
charitable human beings
we're not
and if you've only got to look back at
human history to understand that our
morals are highly
influenced by what society's doing at
the time because if you go back 150
years i would have been a slave
potentially right my family certainly
would have in africa like they would
have had a high chance of being slaves
and at the time
my slave master was not a bad person he
was a good person
you know morally sound per you know and
and and
now obviously that's viewed as being an
awful thing and it's the same within
like the
lgbtq tqq community that you know
at one time
um that was just everyone knew
that
believed that being in a same-sex
relationship was
a terrible thing an evil thing in some
religious um writings now we all accept
it to be
how can our morals of society has
changed the force that's telling us
what's right and wrong what's good and
bad what's valued and what you know has
changed that's the only change that's
happened so i do believe deeply that a
lot of our values um unavoidably come
from our willingness to survive by
taking up the values of the communities
we live in
however when it comes to your personal
values
however they've been shaped usually from
your parents or early experiences i i
just go on based on how things make me
feel and
that seems to be the only indication i
have of what's what's true for me and
what's not
if i'm alone and i watch a video of a
baby
um suffering or crying
and it makes me sad
when no one's around yep
and i'm not having to tweet about my
feelings to the world then i would
assume that that is you know you said
about learning and sorry teaching you've
got enjoyment from that you've always
got
i would assume that's one of your sort
of professional values or something you
value professionally yeah
i've been on a whole like uh quest
across the internet over the last few
months to try and answer this question
of how do you figure out what your
values are um there's this like program
with a life coach that i even did which
is like just just finishing up where
um one of the exercises was
to like go back to your childhood and
think about
kind of on a scale of kind of minus 10
to plus 10 uh minus being really bad and
plus being pretty good like what were
the most salient experiences of your
childhood
and i was like okay this sounds like bs
but all right let me engage with this
process
and
then i i made this list of all these
things that these salient memories from
childhood like you know that time when
my brother new game to my pokemon blue
and i lost my 146 pokemon and that how
how that felt and that time when
whatever um and the facilitator was like
okay let's try and tease out like what
this might tell you about some of your
values i was kind of surprised that a
lot of the stuff that came out of that
if i think about is this a core value
that i live by i want to live by the
answer was yes
and i was surprised by how much of those
experiences where when i was under 10
years old shaped maybe
the values that i've got right now
and so when i think about my values it's
things like i think primarily for me
right now it's like freedom and autonomy
which is why i think i've got this whole
drive to be financially independent to
work medicine part-time rather than
full-time to have be in control of my
own schedule things like
togetherness and kind of working with
other people has always been a really
fun thing for me whether i was in school
or university
studying with friends it's just always
more fun than studying on my own and
that wasn't true for everyone but it was
certainly true for me um teaching on
that list kind of
help helping other people in a way but
like i've got i've got friends for
example who who run charities and they
genuinely feel in their hearts
if there is suffering in the world
and i don't genuinely feel in my heart
when they're suffering in the world um
but i know intellectually that i should
care about this thing and so i will act
in a way that makes me care about the
thing and like donate 10 of my money to
charity every year and all this all this
stuff but i don't actually feel it um
but when i think about how i feel it's
like teaching other people
rather than saving saving lives is the
impact that i care about having and when
i realized this i was like oh okay this
explains why i actually don't really
care that much about medicine like i'm i
prefer
teaching medical students than actually
practicing as a doctor and realizing
that teaching is more of a value for me
than saving lives for example i was like
okay cool this makes sense i can now get
on board with that and not feel bad
about it the other point is that i've
never
cared about really i've really never
cared about finding out what my values
are
because and this is probably goes back
to how i answered that question because
the stimuli that i have to decide all of
these things is like
um how does it make me feel and i think
if you have a good quitting framework
then you will quickly move in the
direction of your values um much faster
than others will quitting framework yeah
like if you have a good a good uh like
quitting framework oh yeah you're very
good at quitting then you'll actually
you'll
so if you're good at
conducting experiments and then quitting
like just a it's like rapid a b testing
right and you can i think i think the
answer really to finding out who you are
and what your values are and getting
your place to a life that you really
love is try something i always say to
young people increase the amount of
experiments you're doing and quit faster
so you go and get a job you're like okay
um i hate this this boss is a dick
because we didn't have any freedom here
or autonomy i hate that part i love the
fashion part but i just hate this
environment because of this and this
quit go and find a job where you have
the bit you liked
and some new sort of
factors and then you go okay well i love
that bit i actually love being a manager
here i'm going to keep the fashion piece
i love the autonomy of being able to
work from home or whatever
quit move on next job you know and i
think that's what i've done in my life
is i never knew what my values were but
i went in the direction of um
i started out in call centers
knew i loved building things bigger
entrepreneurs sales
moved in that direction quit the call
center jobs did about 15 of them start
my own business parts of business i
really don't like
don't want to do those parts don't do
them i still don't do them
and i'm like this is the part within
this bit within business that i love
doing within this industry and i never
was intentional about that there was no
plan it was this rapid increase
experiments you're doing and quit as
fast as you possibly can
um and then you end up i think in a life
that you're but quitting is easier said
than done i have to say it would be
remiss if i didn't say all of this is
underpinned by huge confidence in self
and the fact when i do quit i don't need
a plan and that off i'll be fine a lot
of people don't have that part so they
hold themselves in a miserable situation
because it's a certain one yeah
you know i like uh like when i when i
read that bit of the book the the
quitting framework i was sort of
retrospectively applying decisions i've
made to quit to that that thing of like
suck and hard i was like oh okay this
actually makes a lot of sense um
there was one decision that my mum still
haunts me about
which was
about about a year ago i decided that
you know what i want to take my medical
career seriously and i want to move to
america to do medicine i had a few
friends over there it seemed like an
adventure and it seemed cool but to move
to america from the uk to do medicine
you have to take this like ridiculously
hard exam called the usmle and it's
basically like relearning all of medical
school uh but at like you know a
ridiculous level of detail more so than
we have in the uk and so i started off
preparing for this and i realized that
this is actually really hard
and
the thing that
i reasoned in my mind was
i could do this it's but the reward is
really not worth it like you get to the
end of it i've spoken to some doctors
living working in america and i'm like
yeah you make 400k a year and you're
working a lot and you're going through
this four years of grueling residency
program
and in my mind it was like okay it's
it's hard and the outcome is not worth
it yes therefore i'm just going to quit
that's the worst place to be in life
doing harsh
struggling for nothing yeah
um but then when i have conversations
with my mom it's like oh well
you quit because you're a quitter like
the fact that you found it hard me like
you only quit because it was hard it's
like
no i didn't only quit because it was
hard i also i also crucially quit
because it was like the the reward was
not gonna be worth it but i i didn't
quite have the terminology to express
that until i read it in your book yeah
well i didn't either and it was again
that's why i have to specify that that's
not the framework i've made my decisions
through for my whole life in hindsight
what i'm a very logical sort of first
principle thinker and that's why i'm
able to arrive at peace when i make
these massive life decisions because
it's like oh logically there was no
alternative there was no alternative i'm
not going to do something that's hard
and not worth it but what kind of
insanity is that i am someone that will
do something that's hard and worth it
i'm not and i'm i'm not someone that's
going to quit every time something sucks
i am someone that's going to try and
change it if it's worth it and if i
think it's possible to change i mean my
white you know my girlfriend have an
argument and i go this sucks and [ __ ]
walk out the door that's not who i am i
will try and fight for something if it's
worth it and if i believe it's
changeable and so
logically i think that framework is
robust i think it's solid you talk a lot
about time management
managing one's time you made a lot of
videos about the topic
what would have been some of the other
sort of um tips or tricks that you've
adopted that helped you manage your time
better we talked about time blocking and
um
breaking your
vague to-do list tasks down into
specific ones is there anything else
that comes to mind yeah there's one um
i've i've read a bunch of books around
productivity and stuff there's one
called make time
by these chaps called jake and john
and there's a tip in there which i
genuinely use every day uh it's just
it's called the daily highlight where
it's just similar to gary keller's thing
of the one thing like what is the one
thing you want to do today and then it's
like i define that in the morning okay
what's the one thing i want to do today
record this podcast with you what's the
one thing i want to do tomorrow finish
sample chapter for the book proposal and
then i'll stick a slot in the calendar
for it and then the thing will get done
and on days where i actually do the
daily highlight thing i have about a 50
success rate with actually thinking
about it in the morning i always just
get more done and i feel at the end of
the day oh i've made progress because
i've done that one thing that was most
important and on the days where i don't
i find that like oh i've got these 18
things doing my to-do list oh comedy
book got this am i message coming from
this person who wants to enter an intro
to that person
whereas when i know what that one thing
is i'm like okay cool all i have to do
is just get that one thing done today
and i sometimes think that if i did this
more often if for 365 days i actually
just did the one thing that's the most
important each day i've been making so
much progress i'll be having so much fun
and then i think to myself why don't i
actually just do this every day um but
that's that's one of my main ones that's
life as well it's just
and you when you talked about the
tipping point in your career where you
blew up you were talking about you made
that video about how to study
and i guess the premise of that video
was teaching people how to learn better
you've read a lot of books
as it relates to learning
outside of studying just more generally
what tools have you adopted because
you're some you even you know you've
read my book and you remember all
everything it seems what trips and tips
and tricks have you learned about how to
learn better
yeah um
so
essentially the main one is that we
learn by
testing ourselves rather than by
consuming more stuff
uh like we like in in which is a big
country intuitive like when it comes to
if we if we think about like studying
and then we can kind of broaden it out
like if it comes to studying we think
that to
to learn more stuff i need to get more
information into my brain but what all
the evidence says is that no to learn
more stuff you actually just need to
read it once and then you have to try
your best to get it out of your brain
and that feels hard and it feels tough
and it feels like oh i'm an idiot i
don't know enough but that that like
desirable difficulty is what allegedly
creates the neuronal connections in our
brain to make us actually learn
something
um and so it's similar to working out
like progressive overload when it's
heavy and when it feels hard is when
your muscles are actually growing
because you've got the stimulus for
growth equally when it comes to learning
anything when it feels hard is when
there is a stimulus for the neurons to
grow
or words to that effect and so when it
comes to studying
if anyone is sort of
listening to this has exams coming up
and they are worried about their grades
the the the answer is that they're just
not testing themselves enough the more
you test yourself the better grades
you'll get and this therefore applies
also to every other thing that we're
trying to learn so you know if i'm
learning i was learning how to play
you've got a friend in me on the guitar
the other day and if i'm just playing
through the first two verses of it that
i know already i'm not learning anything
but as soon as i try doing the thing
that feels hard at that point it's like
it the the harder it feels the more i'm
learning and then and then we sleep and
then the connections get solidified um
so it's that that's kind of the main
concept basically test yourself more
whatever that thing is
and the second big one in the research
is spaced repetition that
anything we learn whether it's a fact
for an exam or a song on the guitar
our memory for it will exponentially
decay over time
and the way to make it go into a
long-term memory whatever the skill is
is to interrupt the forgetting curve uh
at spaced intervals so maybe you would
lo you would practice the song on day
one you'd practice it again on day two
then on day five then on day 25 and then
day 105 and as the intervals lengthen
that is the sort of thing that gets this
how to play the song or this fact about
medicine or whatever into a long-term
memory
and most things around learning can
basically be summed up by those two
things active recall i.e test yourself
and space repetition i.e space it out
over time
interesting people are really fascinated
by productivity aren't they they are
yeah i think i heard you say about like
when you put the word productivity in
your content it seems to perform better
yeah
i i often think about this like
so so to me productivity
i think i think to a lot of people
productivity just means efficiency and
creating economic output the way that i
define productivity is just kind of
using my time well and working on things
that are meaningful to me and optimizing
for happiness and so to me this
conversation is productive hanging out
with friends is productive
i was playing playstation last night for
a couple of hours that to me was
productive because i was like
intentionally doing it because i wanted
to take a break from writing
um it's when i feel it's i i feel
unproductive when i know there is
something i want to do and i am not
doing the thing
because i'm scrolling instagram that to
me is unproductive you're not being
intentional with your time exactly yeah
but i think on the internet these days
people use productive as economic output
and the whole like oh i want to be more
productive
it's a
i think partly it's a
virtue signaling thing to some degree as
well yeah
yeah partly it's a it's it's a version
of a virtual signaling thing i think i
think partly it's also like a
self-flagellating thing in a way whereby
i often see comments on my videos where
it's like a productive day in my life
which i'm kind of doing tongue-in-cheek
just because it's funny where people are
like oh my god i watch these videos just
to make myself feel bad
and i'm like oh wow okay
hey this is a this is mostly a joke like
i hope you realize this but but but also
it's like that that's kind of sad that
that comment has got so many upvotes
where oh i feel so i feel like such a
waste man when i watch one of those
videos
and i think there is that like perverse
sense of
people getting pleasure out of the story
they're telling themselves that they are
non-productive or that they are a
chronic procrastinator and to see
someone who doesn't who
is on the surface seemingly so
productive
makes you kind of feel bad about
yourself
um
i wonder if it's similar to like if i
look at my instagram explore page about
a year ago it used to be bikini models
these days the dudes with six-pack abs
and i look at that and there is a part
of me that gets pleasure out of like
flagellating myself and they're like why
don't i look like that yet
and i wonder to what extent that's like
a thing in the world of productivity
that is fascinating
because
i mean that would be driven by
the antithesis of that that's going to
be driven by
a culture where productivity and i'm
getting so much done so i'm going to be
successful and rich in a millionaire and
this is i'm in stealth mode building
this massive business and i've been up
all night look at me it's 4 a.m and i'm
still working that's driving one end of
the spectrum which is making
productivity and being productive and
aspiration for
this generation
and on the other end that's i mean
that's why again
the desire to be productive is so high
and your videos do so well on that topic
and then you have the counter movement
as you always do where it's like i'm
such a procrastinator and then all the
memes
which bang just as hard because
there's been this desire created in
culture to be
you know super productive or even as it
relates to like weight and fitness like
everyone wants to look so good and then
the memes of people sat there with a pot
noodle on their belly like resting like
with their like running shoes on will
also bang just as hard yeah but yeah
it's just a very relevant thing in our
culture which is quite
quite strange that this incessant desire
to be productive i think there's
actually there is a rising
counterculture which is about
being okay with not being produced yeah
no exactly
i am i'm i'm having to pepper in a
pepper that into my videos a lot more
these days um
because i kind of thought it was it was
so obvious that it doesn't need to be
stated that obviously you know
don't be don't be don't seek economic
output and productivity at the expense
of other things that are more important
like health and relationships
uh but clearly that's not a thing that
is obvious and so i'm now
having to caveat a lot of my
productivity advice with like a look
guys let's just define productivity as
you know meaning and fulfillment and
stuff
rather than pure economic output and
it's okay to be intentional and say i
don't do anything today if that was your
intention
i want to just do [ __ ] all like and i
think that's um that's the nuance that's
required in all of that
speaking of productivity one more
company i wanted to tell you about
fiverr.com i mean if there was a company
that's predicated on increasing your
productivity it is fiverr.com where you
can outsource some of the tasks in your
life that you do not want to do
professionally whether it's designing a
website making a thumbnail
editing a video anything you can get it
done on fiverr.com cost effectively and
sometimes if we're talking about
increasing productivity using someone
who's on another time zone which means
work is still happening when you are
asleep which extends the bandwidth of
the amount of hours you have towards
your goals and this month we are using
fiverr to redesign the thumbnails on our
second youtube channel a graphic
designer we found there and i always use
it whenever i have professional tasks
that i need handling that is fiverr with
two rs.com slash
ceo
you talked about relationships at the
start of this podcast you said
you said you you think you alluded to
the fact that you hadn't had much luck
there
when we were talking about knowing
you're enough yeah
what's going on
yeah this is a real problem um so
there's a few like narratives that i've
bought into um subconsciously one of
those narratives is that
i am like a weedy nerd kid this like the
kid that i was when i was 12 years old
and getting slightly bullied in school
and getting grades and stuff but like
not really having anything anything
uh not being valuable as a human being
beyond the fact that i was generating
a stars in exams
that's like one side of it
there's another side but i i'd love to
hear your take on what's the other side
the other side is um
if we're if we're keeping it real it's
like i think it's around
masculinity and what it means to be a
man
and if one if one were to hypothetically
read wikihow articles on how to get
girls or even the vast literature on the
topic um
there is a big thing of
women are attracted to
men like you know people who are so
someone who is a man someone who leads
someone who's like alpha those sorts of
those those sorts of things
and
i think
my kind of default way of being is very
not that and like my idea of fun is
singing disney songs and playing board
games until two o'clock in the morning
with the pizza takeaway rather than
something that a more like macho alpha
type person person would be
and so on the one hand there's that
thing of just be yourself uh of be
authentic self etc etc and
a girl will like that for who you are
and on the other side it's the the thing
of
you will objectively get more success
with women in inverted commas if you
sort of are more of that alpha
type personality
here's the problem yeah please
on the on that particular point before
we move on because i'd love to hear what
you're going to say but um you were you
it sounded like you were saying do i be
myself and dance around listening to
disney um even though it might return a
lower
quantity of smoking hot potential
partners correct
um or the alternative to that is do i be
masculine
um guy and like act outside of self to
generate more
smoking hot partners the issue you have
is you just got to zoom out and you've
got to think about the outcome of both
approaches and how sustainable both
approaches are
all you can be is yourself for a long
period of time
and if you want long long term results
that's the only option you have of
course you can act as something you're
not and pretend you don't like disney
and not listen playboard games and stuff
and you might meet
the wrong person for a short amount of
time
because and it will be a short amount of
time because that relationship will
capitulate the minute they find out who
you actually are and this is there's you
know
um yeah this is this is always for me
the answer is you have to be yourself
you have no choice in that
you do have a choice in being able to
kill some of those confidence issues
which might be self-sabotaging at key
points in the relationship where it
turns into insecurity and results in
jealousy and you know if you're coming
into relation to thinking why the [ __ ]
is this person with me yeah the chance
of you exhibiting jealous behavior and
controlling behavior and manipulative
behavior and insecure behavior and where
are you why are you here why haven't you
texted me back fast enough and is is
high and for me that will put undue
pressure on something that might have
worked otherwise
so go ahead and work on
the the confidence issues but never
ever dare change who you are like the
things you intrinsic do not change those
do not try and act outside of those
because that is that will lead to really
short-term results and you don't
actually want to be with anyone for 50
years that doesn't want to dance and
listen to disney movies with you you
don't actually want to society's telling
you want smoking art
but you don't actually want that you'll
you won't return joy on that you'll
you'll return
status from walking in with a smoking
hot
model that has no brain
but you won't return joy in the long
term and that is the goal that's the
north star does that make sense
it does
yeah
um
on the note of
being yourself
the thing that uh the the thing that i
feel
i feel i feel a contradiction is that
on the one side there's there's kind of
be yourself and on the other side
there's like choose yourself
and
what i what i worry about is what if
this person who i am i.e the kind of
nice guy who like like enjoys disney and
board games and stuff
that's a result of accidental
experiences that i haven't really chosen
for myself
and
should i
instead be thinking okay who's the sort
of person i want to be
well then having having said that i
don't want to be anyone who doesn't sing
along disney songs because they're just
great
um
yeah and you sing along to disney songs
not because you're now being forced
because you enjoy it yeah it's genuinely
fun it makes you feel free to love it
yeah it's so good there you go so that's
that's part of the answer to a lot of
the things we've discussed before which
is going in the direction of the things
that make you feel good don't suppress
things that make you feel good because
then you'll feel [ __ ]
so if that makes you feel good that is
in as far as i'm concerned
you've explored and exploited as you say
and you've and you've and you've found
something you enjoy and don't sacrifice
that for what
for a pretty woman to be stood next to
you yeah that's not in that that trust
me will not be enjoyment that'll be
status
that'll be extrinsic approval right
which is very different from internal
fulfillment
so i would never disregard those things
however
you can as i've done over the last year
and a half say you know what
it when i look at my values and who i i
actually want to be internally
my health this is what i've done is so
foundational to everything
and i really managed to almost like
hypnotize myself somehow
um into knowing that me being in good
shape and me being someone that goes to
the gym every day and prioritizes that
my health is my first foundation
is in line with my happiness
the change in my life the thing that's
put me in the best shape of my life ever
was before as i said in this podcast me
working out was all about women
the minute it became not about women it
stuck
because
because um yeah for so many reasons i
mean i enjoyed the process and i removed
wanting six-pack and i basically don't
have any gym goals now whatsoever my
goal is to go every day it stuck it
became intrinsic it was for me
um and now i go every single day and the
minute we finish this conversation my
pt's waiting for me and i went yesterday
the day before i'll go the day tomorrow
every day okay i don't care
i'm not doing it for anyone else so it
sticks
interesting
that's why your relationship will fail
if you're with someone that you you're
with for external reasons it won't stick
okay
yeah this makes a lot of sense content
content yeah you make a lot of content
and you've must have come to learn a lot
about humans and psychology from
all these videos you make you tinker
around with the titles and the
thumbnails and
um
and you've
become such a big youtuber you've got
millions of subscribers from a very
iterative process of i guess really
understanding what humans will respond
to and what they want what their desires
are what would you give me as advice for
how to make
if i'm a listener a really great content
that people will care about
it's a broad question but there you go
i think it's about
hooking them in with the promise of
something simple and quick
and then
and and if you stop at that point that
is i think where
as kind of as sort of course scammers
and
marketing gurus and stuff were maybe 20
years ago it's hooking them in with a
simple and quick promise
but then
delivering on the nuance of it that i
think people are caring about
more than ever now
and so like
one thing that we've iterated with over
time is
you know
often the success of a video will depend
on how clickbait the title is and
there's no getting around that we've
never found that a title that's less
clickbait uh does better i i did a video
called how writing online changed my
life it absolutely bombed just changed
the title how writing online made me
millionaire suddenly absolutely exploded
people love that like oh this is a quick
solution uh this is a quick path to this
um this this goal that i want hence your
title of happy sexy millionaire
um but we've also found that on videos
where i think oh let's let's dumb the
message down let's just kind of do a
quick five-point listicle without any
examples because people just want the
dopamine hit of advice that sounds
reasonable but they can't action those
videos haven't done as well like people
click on them but then they don't stay
watching
and the videos we found that do the best
is you make a promise at the start and
then you deliver on the nuance
throughout the whole thing and actually
people
at least in my audience and i suspect in
yours and anyone listening actually do
want depth and nuance not just a sort of
surface level two minute long thing that
you would have seen on youtube circa
2005.
um i think you did a pretty great job of
that as
yeah yeah i'm learning i'm
con you know continue to learn youtube's
a bit of a new medium for me so it was
good it's good to get that um
that perspective you you also um you're
very
in in sort of self-aware and honest i i
you wrote something about um why you're
failing
which is uh
i think you wrote a piece which was
detailing why you think you're failing
in life
i think i have this issue where
i often feel like what i'm currently
doing is not quite good enough
because
you know
we're leaving money on the table or
because our team is inexperienced or
because i suck at being a manager or i
suck at being a leader and
although i'm learning to improve in in
all those things
i sometimes feel that oh but it's
it's it's not fast enough i think that's
where the comparison stuff comes in
because
when my peer group was
kind of just my friends in medical
school
and i was doing the youtube stuff and
then i was kind of the only one in the
in the in the pack doing the thing and
so it was like oh anything goes like i'm
not comparing myself to anyone now that
i am sort of a bigger name on youtube
the sorts of people i compare myself to
now are kind of other youtubers with
millions of subscribers the population
for comparison changes and i find that
the more i compare the less good i feel
about the stuff that i've done
and so to get around that i try to just
a not compare at all and b also think
journey before destination all the all
of the mindset stuff but it's easier
said than done and i still feel
internally like right now
we're not using money in the company
like efficiently enough we're not hiring
fast enough we're not doing this fast
enough noting that fast enough um do you
think you'll ever get to a point where
that stops
hmm
because i tell you what yeah what's it
been like for you well i mean no i was
just to say
let's just i mean one way to look at it
is
ali
five years ago when you first started
if you had shown him a picture of younow
yeah what would he have said
that's pretty cool yeah i mean like if
you'd gone if when you made those first
couple of videos you've gone you're
going to have two million subscribers on
youtube you can have all hundreds of
thousands of followers on instagram that
would have had a stroke you would have
had a [ __ ] stroke
there's no way there's no [ __ ] way
that's me yeah
and here you are this is what i was
alluding to earlier it's like the past
version of yourself told you'd be happy
when you got here
but you're not because like you're not
fully satisfied because there's a future
version of yourself that's saying you'll
be happy when you get here
and it just never stops never stops with
it like it seems it seems like at least
on the outside that you've done a good
job of kind of
i mean obviously you're like
particularly successful but like being
okay with that level of success and not
trying to get to
the the next level for whatever that
looks like i think so i think so more
than a lot of people i speak to
i think there's i mean there's still
elements in me that are like i can do
more and i can i can i can take on
bigger challenges in my life but i'm
definitely definitely now detached from
thinking it will have any impact on
the things that matter
won't make me happier would make me more
fulfilled won't be anything at all yeah
i'll be doing it
probably for
either the wrong reasons yep like just
more money therefore i can get private
jets instead of a business class
or
because um
this is not the wrong reason but just
for the challenge of it yep
um all but or thirdly because i want to
solve a problem in the world
as opposed to believing that it will
make it will make me it'll kill my
imposter syndrome or it'll make me feel
more you know
enough
i definitely know that i'm enough
okay i definitely know that much and i
know that nothing's going to change that
positive or negative yeah that's good
it's a good place yeah well i better
because i said in the book do not so um
how how do you think about money
it's a question that you often ask you
guys that i really want to ask you
because yeah obviously
you are rich and
but there are there are more levels of
rich beyond what you currently are so
like they always will be and as you meet
people
as
as i've met people who are kind of
levels of rich above me
where then then i start thinking oh
maybe
it would be nice to be able to afford to
fly first class everywhere that'd be
pretty cool yeah
and i think i wonder if that would
increase my quality of life and i know
there's that there's you know
diminishing returns for money and stuff
sure you know first class versus i
wonder
oh no yeah how do you think about that i
mean so i want to have enough money in
my life that i don't have to do anything
that costs time
that i don't need to spend okay
on things that i don't get joy from
doing so like i basically want to have
so like an airport is a great example
this is why i think i want a private jet
because when i go to the airport you
could spend three hours just checking in
and getting onto the onto the plane and
that's three hours that i'd much rather
doing something i enjoy doing with my
life um and as i talk about in chapter
19 of happy sexy millionaire time is
what we have i refer to these 500 000
chips we have and we get to you know
that's because that's how many free
hours the average human being gets in
their life i would like to have more of
those chips deployable against things
that i really enjoy doing and creating
memories with people i love not standing
in an airport queue for three hours so
if money is going to solve that problem
for me then money does matter it's not
going to make me exponentially happier
like the queue isn't making me miserable
it's not going to move the needle but
yeah but i'd like to make more memories
in my life with with my niece and my dog
you know yeah and with my partner so
that is my view on money at this stage
okay um
convenience uh less time wasted yeah
that's literally it that's literally it
it offers me nothing else okay
yeah
well what do you think of money
i think
i think convenience is a big thing for
me like i also have that thing of
money is useful in so far as it helps me
buy back my time which i can then use to
deploy against things that i care about
but then
as i
kind of
get exposed to more like rich people and
see like the life that they're living
and like you know this idea of thinking
about moving to london
where
like i've been living in my flat that me
and my brother have a mortgage for in
cambridge for the last three years with
a lodger and therefore it's returning 16
a year because i'm not paying rent
bloody but i'm moving to london where
it's like i actually can't afford to buy
a place in london like i could afford to
rent a place in london but it's like i
could rent for a thousand a month or two
thousand or three or four
you know those places that are eight
thousand a month are pretty good i
wonder what it would be you know
can i afford to spend eight thousand a
month on a place that's slightly nicer
that's a little bit more central what am
i optimizing for if i forget a place in
king's cross it's easier for friends to
come visit therefore i can make more
memories there for increase happiness
that way
um and the money thing just sort of
i feel like those
those numbers keep on going up because
you know then you could be like well
having a yacht would be pretty cool
because then i can invite friends on
board and then we can do like jet skiing
and stuff having a private jet would be
really cool because then i can like fly
wherever i want and save my three hours
of time and take my friends out on a
trip having enough money that i'd be
able to fly friends over to visit me
would be sick for my personal happy and
i don't know i feel like the more i
think about this the more i start to
invent justifications for trying to make
more money yeah for the sake of
happiness and fulfillment and stuff
beyond the 75 000 a year that the
studies will tell us leads to
diminishing returns i think the key
thing there and what i've what i said in
my answer is that i don't think it will
make me happier because i'm already i
think at i don't think missing the
airport queue will actually make me
happier yep i don't think it will
because unfortunately unfortunately
fortunately
i'm at a point where i don't think i
could be happier okay yeah like i could
definitely have less think less
annoyances in my life yeah but
fundimentally i don't think i could be
happier than this okay um or more
fulfilled or like comfortable than this
so me killing the cue by getting a jet
is um
is removing an annoyance and increasing
the the
yeah
how intentional i am with my extra two
chips that you'll have
it's not going to move the needle yeah
okay it's not going to be the needle
and if this place was
where we are now which is my home i live
upstairs if it was two times bigger
would i be happier
no
no i wouldn't be
no
okay but
you know i'll probably get a place two
times bigger yeah because i don't know
then i can have bigger parties and maybe
that one's more people will be a more
and more enjoyable memory at some point
but i don't i this is the key thing as i
had to at some point in my life realize
like not buy into the [ __ ]
justification or i'd live my life
running running in that direction
constantly
and i say all the things it's not gonna
make me happier yep
and if i still want it
then i think um
then i'm then it's like it's okay for me
to buy it's like yeah i kind of i kind
of have have similar things so often
i will like
buy something you know i bought one of
those six thousand pound pro display
xdrs with the thousand pound stand that
apple sell the other day just because no
one knows what that is
it's like a ridiculously expensive
monitor that apple sell for like
professionals and i really didn't need
it but i was like it would be kind of
cool to have on my desk
and i knew there was zero way it was
gonna make me any happier i was like oh
it's just it's just kind of cool and my
housemate was like oh your your monitors
arrived how do you feel i was like
like just even even contemplating how i
feel as a result of the fact this
monitor arrived just kind of a bit
baffling to me because obviously it
doesn't make any difference to my day to
happiness it was just something kind of
cool that i could buy the business
expense and i thought why not i think
when i was younger
i used to look forward to purchases more
like you know ordered a playstation game
when we're tracking the delivery waiting
for it to arrive and i was just like
it's just it's just kind of things um
and and the way i often describe it to
people is that
maybe sounds a bit argument but it's
like i feel like my happiness is a 10
out of 10 right now and i really can't
imagine that changing but
it's still kind of cool to spend money
on the things that i want to spend money
on yeah if it's like tech or camera gear
yeah something i care about yeah i
completely agree now and i i actually
don't think i'm a very um flashy person
right now i don't own a car at this
exact moment um i don't have like
designer watches or anything and
typically if i make a purchase it's
based in utility but it's really nice
yeah and that's kind of what you're
describing with your monitor yeah so
like i travel a lot so a suitcase or get
a really nice one yeah but i don't need
a rolex because let's be [ __ ] honest
no one uses it to tell the time anymore
so that would be purely about signaling
and status
um i don't really buy designer clothes
at all i don't really think i have any
designer clothes clothes
i don't really i mean
i have a nice pair of boots or something
yeah but typically it's like i mean this
is like a top man t-shirt i'm wearing
from asos these are top man jeans fits
pretty well yeah these like utility and
fit and matter seem to matter more than
um
in security driven purchases this this
one mental model that i think of which
is that if if you were the only person
in the world would you still buy the
thing
um i think when it comes to like new
apple products yes i would because
like
i can do i can do my work better on a
nicer macbook or on a nicer screen uh
but yeah certainly i probably wouldn't
get an apple watch if i was the only
person on earth because i think the
utility of that is more signally and
more about like this is the sort of
identity i want to portray to other
people and then it is about the fact
that having an apple watch for me given
that i'm not into running is is actually
useful
you've read a lot of books mental models
about mental models and various other
things what are some of the key
principles or key sort of mental models
that have had the biggest impact on your
life
oh
um
there's so many i can imagine that it's
quite hard to yeah i think one of the
main ones is is this thing about the the
money diminishing returns curve about
like beyond about 50 to 70k depending on
what study you look at money doesn't buy
more happiness i often have to like
remind myself of that when i get into
this cycle of
the pursuit of more stuff
um
one of the things i won't really call it
mental model but one of the things i
often come back to is oh i think you
talk about in the book as well uh five
regrets of the dying oh yeah um and i
had have those written on the top of my
to-do list on my daily to-do list
template um
that's that that's a good one
the other one is what is that
for anybody that doesn't know oh yeah so
there there was this like palliative
care nurse or someone who
sorry brony ware that's why she messaged
me on instagram oh no way when i don't
one time i like didn't tag her instagram
so she's just like oh yeah thank you so
much for the pose could you talk about
yeah bro she's amazing brony yeah so she
wrote a book called um the regrets of
the dying or the top regrets of the
dying where she interviewed like
hundreds of people who were on the
deathbed asking them
what are your regrets
um and some of the really common ones
were i wish i'd lived a life true to
myself rather than what others expected
of me uh i wish i'd worked less hard i
wish i'd spend more time more time with
friends and family um can you remember
what the other ones are like you know
what i only focus on the first one yeah
because she was like she said this was
the most common regret of the dying was
i wish i had lived a lifetime to myself
and not what others expected of me yeah
following your intrinsic motivation
rather than status prestige external
exactly yeah it sounds like the other
ones are all actually just yeah like
offshoots of that yeah yeah and people
as they're about to die must have this
amazing retrospective clarity over there
what they did and didn't do right what
didn't didn't matter it didn't matter
that that girl in playground said my
hair was [ __ ]
or this comment on instagram and that
retrospective clara because i i say this
in the book as well this is about the
i talk about how i don't think anybody
believes they're going to die yep
and those people know they're going to
die
so they have that like it's all all the
[ __ ] just fades away and they go i
just want one more day with my son yeah
but also it's it's it's not quite the
same as the whole live every day as if
it were you as if it were your last like
there's that that balance there how do
you think about that balance yeah i mean
so that's actually like fundamentally
bad advice because if i were to live
today like it was my last i would
probably
be doing self-destructive things
like
they're going to be self-destructive
actually yeah yeah like financially i'd
be blowing all my money like yeah so um
or something like that but the merit in
that that i see is um
is living like life itself will come to
an end um at some point um
which for me
means
being
very conscious about the use of
uh your time
i guess
and what you're deciding to do
if today were your last you'd be able to
cut through the [ __ ] that doesn't
matter and so let's say if this life
were your last live every life like it
was your last would be a better thing
then in life yeah you'd really focus on
what matters you know you've talked
about such a diverse range of topics on
your youtube channel
and really about like help you know
helping people as you know as the
teacher you are
become better at what they're trying to
achieve you've talked about productivity
mindset um
finance and all of these things what
what are the what are the things that
you see in young people today that you
think um they most need to solve and
understand
about let's say
about mindset in order to get to that
point where they are
living a fulfilled life
what are some of the you know
and i say this to you because i know how
many how many how many books you've read
thinking specifically here about like
young people and you'll see you're
seeing them in the comments section
you're seeing the problems that they're
trying to solve in their life i think
the main one that i see is a mindset
that work has to be suffering
and
that
like
working hard is like a bad thing and
that
what it looks like if you're
if you're striving for something is that
it it looks like pain um
this is very much the mindset i had
going into medical school where it's
like oh i'm now a first-year medical
student at cambridge university this is
this is supposed to be hard you know
let's get all my big textbooks out let's
like spend ages in the library you know
pulling all-nighters thinking it's a
badge of honor because this is what work
looks like and it looks hard
and
in my from my second year onwards where
i realized hang on like you know the
thing tim ferriss often says like what
would this look like if it were easy
i think
if more young people accepted that work
doesn't have to be suffering it can
actually be easy and fun and you can
have it all provided you find ways to
make it fun and optimize for the things
that are enjoyable
that will solve a lot of kind of
problems when it comes to the things
people often ask me about which is
motivation procrastination burnout and
and all that jazz
i think another
kind of underrated tip which the toxic
productivity people would would crucify
me for is that i think
everyone kind of
like if you want to if you want to live
a life on your own terms
then you do have to solve the money
problem
because we all need to make money we all
need to have that like in in board games
we call it you you call it as an
economic engine
like if you if you want to win in a
board game you always have to figure out
are you going to sell sheep are you
going to get wood are you going to get
owed are you going to get hey like what
is your economic engine going to be
and i think the sooner
a the sooner that can be ticked as a box
or the more aligned the economic engine
can be with the thing you actually find
fun
uh the more you can do that thing of
living life on your terms
because what i never want to be in the
position of is where you know that thing
of well i just got to work the nine to
five so i so i can enjoy the five to
nine because that's like 80 000 hours of
our lives 80 000 chips out of the 500
that we're squandering away
just to survive and obviously there's
it's it's that's so much easier said
than done and a large amount of being
able to take that money box being able
to build that economic engine is based
on kind of privilege and where you've
grown up and circumstances and all that
stuff but i guess kind of from from
where you're sitting you never had that
sort of privilege growing up
and
you kind of succeeded despite it and
yeah it's just that that thing of
accepting
i think a lot of a lot of young people
especially like the gen c the the gen z
folks these days
are in that mindset of
i care about impact i don't care about
money
i think it's very hard to live a
fulfilled life if you're not like if
if you think in that way because then
it's like oh i'm not gonna talk about
money it's weird people talk about money
on the internet et cetera et cetera so
those would be kind of two things that i
would love to
implant into young people's brains yeah
that's a really interesting one there's
been this were absolutely groundswell
over the
last couple of years of i think
millennials are guilty of it too just
all of them want to change the world
and
they don't
really
have a plan or have a specific route to
changing the world
um
or having an impact but they just want
to lead with that which sounds to me a
lot like virtue signaling because i
think the people that end up changing
the world are very specific about what
they're going to do and it's very
passion-driven it's very like specific
passion-driven so they'll say
you know someone that does actually want
to change the world won't actually start
with the end in mind they'll start with
i want to study medicine so i can
understand cancer
and they'll change the world not the gen
z that says i want to i want to change
the world or i want to have a big impact
and you go what's your impact yeah
they go
the world
how
do you ask too many questions
i want to have that so for me whenever i
see that in my dms or when a kid comes
up to me
uh
when i've been speaking on stage or
something is i want to be a public
speaker i go what would you want to talk
about
it's like
go and have go and live a life worth
talking about like go and have an
experience go like go through some [ __ ]
and then you'll the consequences you're
a public speaker i had no intention of
ever being a public speaker there's a
consequence of
of having some creating a life where i
had some [ __ ] to talk about you know and
i think younger generations have that
the wrong way around they're so obsessed
about oh wouldn't it be great to create
an impact
but have you come across um effective
altruism no i'd like to see here yeah so
it's like this um this movement this
community that talks about how
um
doing good in the world and like having
an impact is actually like
scientifically measurable and can be
done in evidence-based kind of ways
and so
they you know there's a few like
charities and um programs tied to that
one of them is give well and they uh do
an evidence-based analysis of the
charities in the world to figure out
what is the most bang for your buck
what's the what's the highest roi on
money donated in terms of lives saved or
are some other outcome measures and you
find that it's some pretty rogue
charities that that come out on top here
for example the against malaria
foundation
um on average it costs somewhere between
two thousand and three thousand pounds
to buy enough malaria nets to
statistically be able to literally save
a life
um and that's like a lot cheaper than
most people would think and if someone
would say to you now you know steve you
can donate three grand and you literally
save a life you'll be like oh great have
three guys um
and and so the idea behind effective
altruism is that given that like like
you can actually measure the impact of
charities um and where i was going with
this is that
you can therefore measure the impact of
a career and relate it kind of to money
if you need to
so they've done an analysis of what
being a doctor is like and in the
western developed world
uh a doctor will save around seven lives
throughout the course of their entire
career
and this is not taking into account the
fact that if i wasn't a doctor the next
the next person would have gone into
medical school and been a doctor in my
place because in the uk we have more
people applying to medicine than there
are places if you are the only doctor in
i don't know
sub-saharan africa or
in a country or something and then you
stop being a doctor that obviously has a
big impact but most of the people
listening to this are not in that
position
and so the way that i think of impact is
in terms of like counterfactual impact
i.e what is my impact compared to if i
didn't if i didn't exist if i wasn't
doing my thing
and i often will see comments on videos
from people being like oh
you're a you're a sellout for leaving
medicine in the middle of a pandemic to
like i don't know make youtube videos
something something bs like that
and i'm like yeah i can see why that's
the narrative that you're telling
yourself but actually i'm not special as
a doctor like i have no unique value to
add as a doctor two years fresh out of
med school anyone basically who has gone
through medical training in the uk
because it's pretty good medical
training could do as good a job if not
better uh than i can of being a doctor
but where i have counterfactual impact
where i am kind of unique and the impact
i'm providing is in the fact that i have
a youtube channel that teaches people
and inspires people stuff
and if for kind of the dms and stuff or
anything to go by you know people be
like oh my god i got into medical school
because of your videos i was from this
background where no one ever applied to
medicine no one thought about going to
oxbridge and i got there you know in
part thanks to your videos thank you so
much and i feel like the impact i can
have on the world by creating content on
the internet and speaking to a camera in
my bedroom
is arguably greater than the impact i
would have kind of just being a doctor
not that there's anything wrong with
just being a doctor of course
did you hear that mum
are you listening
at least that's what i try and tell
myself yeah you should say that to her
we'll just we'll we'll snip it that yeah
yeah
have you seen this i just uh
stumbled across this no but i completely
get that and i think um
i think yeah i think and it's funny
because me being
selfish in my life has been the thing
that's allowed me to help way more
people developing my own thinking my own
skills my own ability to do this stuff
has been the able to create a platform
in which i can help more and i spoke to
a monk or i think he was a monk about
this when i got to ask this world famous
monk he was doing this massive talk in
new york my one question was am i
selfish for having spent the last
five years of my life growing wealth and
developing myself and my skills um
should i have run off to africa and
started trying to you know
save one life at a time and his response
to me was that you can't pour out that
for others that which you don't have
yourself so he likened it to a bottle
and said you have to fill the bottle and
to be able to pour out into other
people's glasses so by filling your
bottle as long as you are being um
you're doing good with your full bottle
then that's a incredibly
noble thing to be doing and
yeah that's something that um naval
rovicon says as well which is that if
you want to have an impact then you want
to get rich and you want to get famous
as well because people who are rich and
favors just have more impact than people
who are not because you can just deploy
more capital and social capital towards
the things that you care about to make
more of an impact so optimizing for
wealth and fame when you're young
and while building skills while having
fun um
i think you know there are worse things
chmath talks about that as well chamath
papadea yeah said his name papadilla he
on stage says that
wealth allows you to impose your opinion
and viewpoint on the world so he says
who would you rather having all the
money some like rich russian oligarch
who has 75 yachts or me who has a desire
to
um you know like elon like take us make
us multi-planetary and and
solve the carbon problem and so with
resources you can impose your world view
of good or bad i guess on the world and
that is impact maybe we're just trying
to make excuses for
wanting to be really [ __ ] right to
justify happy sexy millionaires good for
the world yeah exactly no no but to be
fair even this podcast like this podcast
was very expensive it's very expensive
to run the equipment's very expensive
and this has been enabled the people
we're reaching now that are listening to
this has been purely enabled by by the
five years of selfishness and me
building a business for myself i do this
as i said i don't even know if we make a
profit i not really look to be honest
from this podcast necessarily but um i
do it because of the huge enjoyment it
gives me and the impact that we see in
the comments section and the messages we
get and that make that is such a selfish
thing for me it makes me feel really
good
have you come across a book called the
elephant in the brain no oh this is like
a whole it's like really well written
it's like all of the studies around what
drives human behavior and the main
thesis of the book is that
uh we're all ultimately selfish a lot of
the stuff we do is for signaling but
there is like a pr secretary in our
heads that convinces even us that our
motives for doing something are not
selfish and they are in fact altruistic
yeah um and there's a quote from
apparently from jp morgan which is that
a man always has two reasons for doing
something a good reason and the real
reason
and so whenever people ask me why do you
do youtube
it's always that right do i want to say
it's because i enjoy helping people and
like making content that inspires
or the real reason which it because it
you know social status prestige money
etc i like being recognized in the
streets it's kind of cool
i mean i think it's a bit of both
but
and that's fine because that's the truth
yeah
and it's the truth for everyone there'll
be someone sat at home thinking no no
when i give five pounds to him this
person i'm purely doing it because
i want to give the money i'm sure you
want to but the reason why is because it
might make you feel good
right or because um it might make you
look good
and if you think i'm wrong
all you've got to do is go back in
history whereas once upon a time
your family members with with very
similar genetics to you might have been
whipping black people yeah like and you
and you wouldn't have thought that was a
morally bad thing to do
society is heavily controlling what we
think is good right noble virtuous and
as soon as we can admit that i think we
can actually create a better world yeah
that is a vacant of this like virtue
signaling what's the right hashtag to
use what am i meant to say who am i
meant to be for others
i think it's a form of liberation to
admit that yourself yeah yeah i think
that's really good um there's a the
there's a phrase that a blogger friend
of mine uses called servant hedonism
which is that
you like by serving others uh and and
optimizing for serving others at when
you're making decisions in your life
you're in fact kind of making yourself
more hedonic more more more happy and
that is actually a reasonable and as
long as you can admit that to yourself
there's that's a pretty reasonable way
of living life
listen thank you for your time ali thank
you it's been a very long time yeah very
lots of fun and you're such a diverse
character that's really why i wanted to
speak to you because you have such a
wealth of knowledge across multiple sex
sectors and industries and topics and
themes and i find that um and that comes
from your curiosity i can tell you're
deeply curious i can tell you know
um and
therefore you this is again also why i
think you've done so well in as a
content creator who is an educator and a
teacher because
you are your curiosity has
sent you in search of answering complex
questions that a lot of people don't
actually have the um the time or the the
skill to know how to answer and then
your ability to break those conclusions
down in ways that people understand that
aren't alienating that aren't too big
words for me
timothy in my bedroom that doesn't
didn't go to cambridge is a real skill
and it's also a testament to the fact
that you actually understand the things
you're talking about
because being able to simplify as we
know simplify complex ideas is the is
the best evidence that someone
understands those ideas so thank you
that's that's very kind of you to say um
and we're incredibly gracious to have me
on your book had a big impact on me the
the mental models in their decision
making the the chip stuff with time
genuinely has changed decisions that
i've made in my life um so thank you for
that and if anyone's listening to this
who hasn't read the book would recommend
the audiobook in particular which is
narrated by you yes yeah
yeah and you've got a book coming soon
haven't you uh two years from now so two
years from now yeah i'll reach out to
you to promote that closer to the time
we'll have you back on when you're ready
yeah thank you so much i appreciate you
thank you
[Music]
you